Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Ci sono tre parole chiave
che la musica risveglia:
creatività, umorismo ed energia.
Cominciamo con la creatività.
La musica insegna
che la ricchezza non sta tanto
nella nostra dotazione iniziale,
quanto in ciò che ne facciamo.
Nelle variazioni
"Ah, vous dirais-je, Maman"
Mozart sceglie un punto di partenza
semplice, quasi povero.
Una nota filastrocca infantile.
(Musica)
Ma poi ci mostra
quanto lontano possiamo andare
se questa partenza è, anche,
il punto d'attacco
di un processo creativo.
Ecco allora che, con questo
nostro materiale povero,
possiamo costruire,
come se fosse un Lego fatto di suoni,
una deliziosa scena di marionette.
Che trasformano il pianoforte
in un palcoscenico,
e creano un teatro dei suoni.
(Musica)
Oppure possiamo reinventare
il suono della filastrocca,
affidandola a quattro campanili
che idealmente si rispondono
da punti diversi dello spazio.
(Musica)
O addirittura, la filastrocca
può essere l'occasione
per la più spettacolare delle metamorfosi,
per cui il pianoforte
si trasforma in un'intera orchestra
nella quale, anziché essere
i campanili a rispondersi,
sono famiglie diverse di strumenti.
(Musica)
C'è una sintesi molto bella
di tutto questo,
fatta dallo stesso Mozart,
in una lettera, quando scrive:
"I nobili non devono sposarsi
in base all'amore,
ma solo in base all'interesse.
Ma noi, povera gente comune,
non siamo nobili e neanche ricchi!
Siamo invece umili e poveri,
e di conseguenza non abbiamo bisogno
di una moglie ricca,
in quanto la nostra ricchezza
si estingue con noi,
perché l'abbiamo tutta
nella nostra testa."
Come vediamo,
questa ricchezza creativa
ha molto a che fare
con la capacità di cambiare
prospettiva sulle cose.
Ecco perché la musica può risvegliare,
in alcuni casi, anche l'umorismo.
Nella sua Sonata Opera 10 N. 2,
Beethoven finisce il secondo movimento
in un clima stupefacente,
di bellezza, solitudine
e rarefazione poetica.
(Musica)
È il Beethoven delle grandi
altezze spirituali,
degli ideali elevati
e del più profondo sentire.
Con un clima del genere,
uno si aspetterebbe
che il movimento successivo,
che chiude la sonata,
cominci a tono, cioè nello stesso clima.
E invece -
(Musica)
Altro che altezze spirituali:
una rozza fanfara da caserma,
con un'aria da canzonaccia da osteria!
Non dico -
(Musica)
ma quasi.
Osteria Numero Nove,
i soldati fan le prove - e mi fermo.
(Risate)
Quindi, primo elemento umoristico:
la smentita flagrante,
il brutale contrasto con le aspettative.
Ma la sorpresa è doppia:
perché è vero che
il materiale musicale è rozzo,
ma il trattamento che Beethoven
ne fa non lo è affatto.
Sentite cosa succede.
(Musica)
Le voci entrano una dopo l'altra,
e si rincorrono.
Questa tecnica è il contrappunto.
Nome che già dal nome stesso, temibile,
evoca profondità speculativa,
dottrina, artificio teorico.
Quindi, secondo motivo umoristico:
il dissacrante connubio
tra materiale da caserma
e un trattamento musicale
sofisticato e di prim'ordine.
Quindi, tra sacro e profano.
È il Beethoven contadino,
scarpe grosse ma cervello fino.
(Musica)
Non è finita.
Quando sembra proprio che Beethoven
abbia indossato la parrucca
e abbia deciso di giocare
a travestirsi da papà Bach,
e quindi fare il piccolo Bach,
Beethoven stesso,
con un doppio squillo, un doppio segnale
(Musica)
manda tutta la dottrina
e la scienza a farsi benedire,
a vantaggio di uno stile
molto più modernamente dinamico.
(Musica)
Il terzo motivo umoristico
è quindi la liquidazione.
Beethoven si disfa, da solo,
del dubbio gioiello di oreficeria,
del dubbio pezzo di oreficeria
che egli stesso si era costruito.
Infine, non facciamo in tempo
ad esaltarci per questo nuovo stile,
modernamente dinamico ed energetico,
che tutto improvvisamente si inabissa,
scomparendo ingloriosamente
nell'indistinto borbottio
di una pentola di fagioli.
(Musica)
Come si vede, l'umorismo ha a che fare
con un continuo cambio
e ribaltamento di prospettive.
Lo definisce perfettamente Milan Kundera,
nella raccolta di saggi
"I testamenti traditi",
dove parla dello humor:
"Lampo divino, che rivela
tutta l'ambiguità morale del mondo,
e la profonda incompetenza dell'uomo
a giudicare gli altri.
Lo humor, l'euforia che nasce
dal conoscere la relatività
delle cose umane.
Il bizzarro piacere
che deriva dalla certezza
che non ci sono più certezze".
E dunque, l'umorismo è una prospettiva
sulla relatività delle cose.
Infatti nessun fanatico lo possiede -
a dire la verità, salvo i cattivi
dei film di James Bond,
che fanno una vistosa eccezione;
ma in generale,
l'umorismo spiazza e fa riflettere,
generando nuove idee e nuove energie.
E siamo alla terza parola chiave: energia.
Nella prima ballata,
Chopin introduce il secondo tema,
lasciando dissipare completamente
l'energia che egli stesso
ha creato poco prima.
(Musica)
Perché lo fa?
Perché vuole creare una situazione
tipicamente ad energia zero.
Cioè una situazione con un tono lirico,
quasi da confessione intima.
Con il senso, in questa
confessione individuale,
di qualcosa di profondamente soggettivo,
personale e appunto unico e individuale.
E anche con la sensazione,
sentite un po' che meraviglia -
(Musica)
di una luce che bagna la musica
di nobile solitudine.
Il tutto sottovoce.
Per tutto questo, chiaramente,
serve una situazione a energia zero.
(Musica)
Verso la fine del pezzo,
riprende lo stesso tema,
ma questa volta in una situazione
di energia massima.
E quindi, anziché arrivarci
da una fase di dissolvenza
ed evaporazione dell'energia,
ci arriva una fase spettacolare
di ricarica energetica.
(Musica)
L'effetto è uno spettacolare
impatto sullo stesso tema,
nel quale però, questa volta,
a causa dell'alta energia
i tre valori di prima
sono completamente ribaltati;
per cui non c'è più il tono lirico,
ma il tono diventa grandiosamente epico:
nell'attualità bruciante
del sentimento dell'ora presente,
il respiro emozionale
della storia del mondo.
Non c'è più il tono
di una confessione individuale,
ma la sensazione
di una coralità collettiva.
E infine, quella luce di nobile solitudine
si ribalta nella gloria
di una pienezza condivisa.
(Musica)
La musica ci mostra quindi l'energia
come principio trasformativo delle cose.
Chiudiamo con un brano che sintetizza
tutte e tre queste parole chiave.
Abbiamo definito la creatività
come capacità di cambiare
punto di vista sulle cose
e di mettere a frutto
le risorse, soprattutto.
Ebbene, in questo brano,
che è il terzo
dei Tre Preludi di Gershwin,
Gershwin addirittura mette a frutto
le risorse di due intere
tradizioni musicali:
la classica e il jazz.
C'è inoltre dell'umorismo,
perché l'introduzione
la mette giù in grande stile,
annunciando solennemente
qualcosa di sinistro e di minaccioso -
(Musica)
che però non arriva.
La montagna partorisce
il proverbiale topolino:
al posto di qualcosa
di minaccioso e sinistro,
arriva una situazione fumettistica,
che io chiamerei appunto
"Malavita da fumetto".
(Musica)
E da ultimo, l'energia:
è proprio un pezzo,
questo, ad alto voltaggio
in cui l'energia tiene insieme
situazioni diverse
unificandole in un ritmo mozzafiato,
che non dà tregua allo spettatore.
E su questo, chiudiamo.
(Musica)
(Applausi)